dans son restaurant crêperie du quartier
montchapet johan cercueil est de retour
en cuisine depuis bientôt un mois le
jeune chef propose milliers soir des
menus à emporter comme beaucoup d'autres
il est passé de l'assiette à la
barquette
pour le moment donc en à peu près une
bonne dizaine de truites à faire et puis
à peu près autant de filets mignons et
puis encore quelques quelques galettes à
accra faire au fur et à mesure voilà là
c'est total à l'adaptation donc des
clients les voit un petit peu
différemment ils sont tous au rendez
vous donc on est très content quelques
rues plus loin dans la brasserie de
corinne père gironnais c'est l'heure du
retrait et les clients sont là aussi il
fait du confinement quand on a su que
corinne spectre il faisait des plats à
emporter on s'est dit il faut qu'on
continue à faire vivre le marais et en
plus c'est toujours très bon ce qu'elle
crée donc façon on va pas la laisser
tomber des propos touchants forcément
pour la gérante mais qui n'empêche pas
l'inquiétude
honnêtement c'est pendant quelques plans
porte et qu'on va gagner notre vie me
rattraper ce qu'on est en retard mais là
la raison numéro un et je pense que
c'est très important c'est de surtout
garder de lien social avec le client des
clients fidèles et solidaire sur
lesquels peut aussi compter richard
bernigaud et de pêche du jour donc
aujourd'hui c'était cabillaud qu'ils
n'auraient nulle et condiments citroën
cible le chef du restaurant
bistronomique s'est lancé dans la vente
à emporter juste avant le week-end de
pâques avec deux places au départ et
très vite il a dû s'adapter à une
demande croissante
je suis dit voilà chaque semaine va
proposer une nouvelle formule en restant
sur des produits de saison en faisant
travailler au maximum de producteurs
aussi locaux et
au final je trouve que c'est une belle
chaîne qui continue et qui va continuer
c'est après la réouverture
richard bernigaud sert déjà 250 clients
par semaine pour lui comme pour beaucoup
de restaurateurs la vente à emporter est
peut être un nouveau métier mais elle
sera sûrement un complément
indispensable dans les semaines ou mois
à venir
s'ils ne peuvent accueillir qu'un nombre
de clients réduit